I'm about to use my medical experience
to tell you five of the healthiest items
you can get in Taco Bell and the one
that's the most unhealthy but I need
some help for this video so please
welcome Andrew from babish culinary
Universe oh hey what's up man we're
gonna be talking Taco Bell and really
where I'm making this decision from is
four factors one sodium levels two fiber
three protein and calories and it's
really all about trying to keep it
reasonable rather than super healthy or
super unhealthy does that make sense
absolutely whole ingredients fewer of
them less preservatives it's good it's
gooder for you and you're going to be
taste testing you excited it's Barry I
love Taco Bell okay well let's get
started
you see a Taco Bell what's the first
food you go for
double decker Taco the one with the
cheese you go for a soft shell taco but
the hack that I want to give people is
that there's a specific way to order a
soft shell taco that is healthy it's
called Alfresco oh where they basically
insert vegetables to replace some of the
saturated fatty components of the food
like the sour cream like the cheese so
by vegetables you mean a little bit of
lettuce and tomatoes well I've heard
tomatoes are fruits but only because Dan
told me that earlier oh I just got
caught on camera saying it I never live
that down the idea here is it's
calorically dense it's 150 calories in a
little package which is nice you have
some protein content because of the
chicken and because you're going
Alfresco style you only have four grams
of fat with one gram being saturated fat
but what I am going to say is that taco
it's got some it's got some rings on it
you know like a good tree like a good
piece of Oak you know it's been
compressed it's kind of all mushed in
there yeah tortilla is very soft which I
really like the chicken is clearly
marinated I mean look at the
marination and they were not supposed to
put sour cream in the Alfresco style so
they've let us down but that's okay yeah
that's fine because that's what's
probably going to happen when you go and
you
they're not going to get you a order
this looks like real chicken it's not
like a chicken patty product or anything
I see real grain and musculature okay
the lettuce is on top which is that's a
taco okay uh the cheese the cheese is
very finely shredded but you can see it
but it's still it's all in one place
yeah it's all in one place you see it's
still kind of kind of broken up and
that's probably because they're putting
anticoagulants and anti-caking agents on
it which just leads to a bad experience
plus you're getting extra starch in
there that you don't need you don't need
that
um
a lot of sour cream in one bite
a lot of sour cream a lot of unmelted
trees oh we're having different
experiences eating the same food right
now I can feel the separate shreds of
cheese in my mouth I'm gonna try the
chicken outside and see what we're
working with here we got some grill
marks on it that's pretty cool you think
those are legitimate definitely painted
on there by a robot that hates humans
the great part about their website is
that they give a great nutrition fact
section for each food this is a
calorically appropriate food if you're
trying to be low calorie there's some
protein in there what ingredient would
you add to this to give it a little a
pepper a hot sauce yeah give it a little
kiss on there and I don't know how you
feel about that because of the sodium
but hot sauce is just the meal saver
everything that we get from here load up
that hot sauce yeah and there's there's
ways to improve the spiciness without
adding salt there's ones with zero
calories there's one with zero sodium
with vinegar as the main component so
there's ways to do it hold on a second
this is a real moment I have a chicken
bone in my chicken no no
that's never happened before in the
history of Taco Bell it's your first
time trying it dude this is my first
time and this is a sharp bone their
chickens don't even have Bones hold on a
second can we Sue food number two
bean burrito why do we go Bean fiber
protein generally speaking low-fat yes
well what happens is part of the fiber
your body can't digest so it goes
through but then the bacteria without
naturally live in your gut they digest
it and what do they do
fart and then you fart so so you're it's
not you're even your fart that makes me
feel a whole lot better yeah so you're
gonna blame it yeah you can blame it on
the bacteria I'm gonna do that next time
at a party
so we have the bean burrito but this
time instead of the red bean sauce Which
packs on the sodium because the
traditional bean burrito has 1040
milligrams of sodium which is half your
day's sodium for an average person in an
average situation for an average
nutrition perfect label I'm gonna go on
an 11 and say that seems like too much
salt but you can lower it by removing a
red bean sauce and just putting tomatoes
in like we requested let's see if they
listen you want to see Tomatoes okay I
see Tomatoes okay but I feel like
there's still red bean sauce on here
isn't that not red bean sauce it's a hot
sauce yeah
on these
intention that's insane well you gotta
love it but there are some onions there
are some Tomatoes there are some beans
which are ingredients that I would say
are healthy
very big dinosaur Bean it's all bean I
mean
I'll tear this apart from a culinary
perspective if you want garbage
what what why elaborate on the garbage
there's very little flavor the texture
is only soft and Squishy yes the beans
are really all there is yeah and I know
some people like bean burritos this
might be a bias for me but that's just
not the core component that I want I
need some rigidity here okay otherwise
we just have a big old
look what happens
so now we're on to the power
the veggie Powerball
do they only have three vegetables at
Taco Bell I just see these Tomatoes yeah
probably that sucks and I still don't
think tomatoes are vegetable no matter
how hard we try today oh I keep there's
also some avocado ranch sauce on here
this little amount of sauce has soybean
oil cultured buttermilk water avocado
cage-free egg yolk vinegar white wine
thank you
and milk and eggs that are certified
vegetarian what is all that for I know
it's it's preservatives and
anticoagulants but like did they taste
it and they were like you know what
it doesn't have enough a lot of
ingredients that we can pronounce are
actually safe ingredients have been
tested but my question is why this is a
densely caloric rich food 400 calories
you got fiber in there okay this is
guacamole yeah we're missing guacamole
we didn't get any guacamole yeah no
guacamole that's a vegetable that's a
good vegetable right it's good it's good
fat unsaturated fat all right I'm gonna
start with each individual component
then I'm gonna mix it up into a big
monster recipe I don't have any skills
so I'm just gonna eat it oh God oh my
God the average sauce is just water this
rice tastes like chlorine
I'm not joking there is a there is an
astringent quality I would venture to
say musky I mean I like that these are
black beans though black beans have
virtually no fat
oh really yeah and they're very good for
you protein protein fiber dare I say the
healthiest item in Taco Bell is right
here in front of us what is it it's one
ingredient
made up of seven ingredients it has
protein it has fiber it's black beans no
it's black beans 50 calories 3 grams of
protein three grams of fiber and it
looks delicious and you know who's gonna
love this the bacteria inside your gut
bacteria
what's in the black beans it's normal
yeah except for natural flavor what the
hell is that I ate all of it oh my God
you did 50 calories is the healthiest
thing I could eat might as well maximize
the gains what do you think folks you
want to look like this you want to look
like this
each beans the black bean crunchwrapped
Supreme bless your Taco Bell this is the
hottest ticket at Taco Bell this is
popular but we have to make it al fresco
of course we have to replace the sour
cream with diced tomatoes I'm not trying
to die so we have ourselves a Crunchwrap
Supreme I'm gonna treat this like a
patient encounter hello
my name is Dr varshovsky
I'm going to make an incision
vertically
really
isn't it oh no it feels so much more
visceral with that
beautiful oh look at that crosstalk look
at that look at that honestly this looks
healthy I mean there's a lot it's mostly
the beans are cut so nicely
you come under the middle of the beach
that is surgical he did a surgical thing
yeah this is good that's a good knife is
that your knife is it yeah it is yes it
is get this nut I'm gonna buy this knife
where is this available it's available
on Amazon right now we're buying this on
Amazon right now how many calories we're
looking at for this it's around 500
calories well it's so for a small meal
yeah it's a meal yeah yes if you're
having three meals a day that's 1600
calories a day that's very reasonable
you know three of these a day before
yeah well I'm kidding I'm sorry honestly
it's not bad though the fried tortilla
brings a lot of flavor yeah which it
adds oil it adds cooked corn which is a
very flavorful ingredient this isn't
what I would call a healthy food yeah I
would call it the healthier option yes
the least healthy thing in Taco Bell
high in saturated fat high in calories
high in sodium high in carbs low in
fiber the breakfast
crunchwrapped sausage Supreme oh God
yeah I'll take a breakfast crunch thing
it's so markedly thicker and different
yeah and there's no beans in this one
there's no beans so you're not getting
the fiber I'm actually gonna like it and
you get a hash brown you get sausage you
get egg you get cheese you get dressing
there's a lot happening on this little
piece of food yeah my cholesterol is
high there's so much saturated fat what
is it 47 grams of total fat in this tiny
little thing that's insane that's a bomb
under what circumstances should people
eat this
you're lost
in the desert
well that was a lot it was a lot this
tastes like the whole thing went through
the deep fryer just for fun that's
factual what I'd really like to do is
make not only like a better you know
Whole Food version but also when it's a
little bit healthier okay and it still
has lots of flavor and you make it
yourself you meal prep it you can freeze
it we could switch rolls we switch rolls
okay so I'll taste test
you make it health not something you'd
cook I don't know how to do that well
I'd love to do that for you on my
channel I'm going to do a Basics episode
and I'd love you to swing by and try it
let's do it click here to check out that
episode and as always stay happy and
healthy foreign